are you touching yourself we'll shut it
down and act right it's time for the
dang episode
set me free set me free set me free just
don't suck you bye
come on now enjoy the destination
nahshon nahshon america fantasy painting
on the wall
yes now the two
to come all
time slips away from you
don't hesitate oh why must we be weighed
when we're
and that right there - Stevie starlight
Stevie starlight and and that's hit his
hit song come over and that music video
is located on the youtubes you can get
on there and get you a free hit of
Stevie's starlight whenever you want and
he came in here a while back and did a
music review with us and man it was
really enjoyable it was really you know
he's a special he's a special he's just
something that you know sometimes the
the the Lord just takes a syringe and
just inject something something unique
into the universe and that is Stevie
starlight and that uh that is who he is
and that is his song come over here's a
new album out - I think somewhere out
there so you can go peep it back it's me
it's me back in studio is or not it's me
but it's interesting to be back in my
own studio or studio because Chris
D'Elia was here
[ __ ] critter Delano was here
[ __ ] Krispy Damiani was here okay and
who knows what he did he it look I
remember when I came back in after he'd
been in here it smelled like a um you
know sometime you'll see that fancy
store to have an airport Johnston and
Murphy's and a lot of people don't know
the history of Johnston and Murphy's and
Johnston at Murphy's were two men that I
mean they had wives but they wasn't
thinking about them let's say that and
they would you know they were constantly
trying to just dress better than each
other and you know tie their shoes
faster you know I think it was on a man
I think I could look at a Benjamin
Johnson and Dustin Murphy and Benny and
dusty and they would
you know they were always trying to have
pants that could fit as good as they
could and just oh just Oh button my
shirt as fast as I can and they would
just you know everything was just
perfect and they just looked at all just
so perfect and they kept like trying to
outdo each other one of them would put
on a bow tie and one of them would put
on a little you know a little whoa a
tight small scarf you know and just so
tight he could only whisper his throat
wasn't fully open and then when I'm
gonna wear real tight socks and just so
tight that his legs would look a little
plumper because of the blood and the the
extra foot meat would kind of coagulate
upward it would boil upward and stretch
upward it you know stress upward into
his legs because the tight socks and
that was Johnston and Murphy and finally
they just fell in love with each other
and that's really if you notice that
store if you go in there nobody's in
there it's at the airport and it smells
fancy it smells leathery it smells like
somebody just took a damn cow and just
beat the walls with it I mean it just
smells all leather they might even have
a little bit of leather dust and they're
sprinkling it around it might be fate
that fake leather
you know sometimes you'll see someone
who a little I bet if you go in there
around opening time 6:00 a.m. or
whenever whenever Benny and dusty allow
their little store to be open you'll see
somebody with a little can of [ __ ]
leather dust sprinkling ice [ __ ] and
hiding it under two different the
mediums and and you know putting a
little in the bottom of the sock just to
get that smell in there but if you go in
there it's fancy and that's exactly what
it smelled like when I got back here
from from crust what does an encrusted
uh crust
[ __ ] crust the apeshit when I when I
got back from when crusty up [ __ ] took
over the podcast it smelled fanciest
Monica Johnston in Murphy's so and that
story is kind of a beautiful story is
kind of like the Romeo and Juliet of the
fashion industry because here you had
two men they had wives
and they had lawn mowers you know and
one of them had one of them gas-powered
blenders if he would you know he'd using
it you know down in Fort Lauderdale
Beach her down in Destin to get the dam
to make a margarita you know he had a he
had a he had a eighty-five outboard
motor on a damn blender and he makes him
margarita got now he can make a
margarita so fast bruh you could lose
your arm that's how quick that blade was
going you could lose your damn arm you
could lose somebody else's arm that's
how how much the blade would spin but
but that's you know that's the smell
that was in here was a fancier smell a
smell I'm not used to and that is the
type of smell you get when you have a
crisp D'Antoni in here and crisp dan
tony is a male comedian you know who he
is and he knows who he is he's a
phenomenal young fella Christopher and
he crisp before I'm not sure how he says
it but he was in here and we switched
and a happy belated April Fool's because
dude I uh I forgot we did it and I knew
but I was like what is this gonna be
like and when I saw him in the studio
when I saw Chris in this studio it blew
my mind I was like what it felt like
I've never lost my virginity with a vag
on like in my vagina cuz I don't have a
vagina but I imagine a little bit that
that was kind of what it was like you
know because there was nothing happening
and suddenly it was just overwhelmingly
happening and there was this tall sort
of bearded you know kind of vestibule of
a man and he was like a three or four
story man he was so tall and he had like
you know his voice was deeper and he had
like a long stringy hair and he just
reminded me of just god damn he reminded
me of just everybody all wrapped in one
from the second season a lost
and uh and he next thing I know he was
there and he was just invading my little
space and then it was gone I mean it was
over so anyway that's that got kind of
homework all of a sudden but what I'm
saying is I love tits
um but yeah I'm sure I can only imagine
how I wish I wish I could have said hey
let's see some reaction videos from
people on YouTube just the surprise of
uh of Drizzt drifts Minh what's his name
charisma Cornelia being in here but it
was fun and it was hard honestly it was
hard being on his podcast
I didn't there's nothing to do there you
go to his house and let me tell you his
house bro it's crazy they have a
drawbridge at Chris's at Chris's house
they have a drawbridge and it has people
dude it comes down and then there's
people drawing on it it has puns built
into it there was two guys drawing like
what are y'all drawing but like whatever
he wants whatever he wants to die and
you know and then you go up there and
and uh and you get up there and there's
an old man standing there at the top of
this hill and he's like do you know the
password
son and I was like [ __ ] you dude it was
actually just a homeless guy had nothing
to do with Chris's place but you get
over his place man it's nice they got so
many stairs huh I thought I was a damn
cheat Macha maccu picchu you know I
thought I was at makuu damn pico or a
fake maccu picchu remember um you know a
lot of cruises if you go down to Mexico
or uh if you get on to Mexico a lot of
cruises go down to somewhere where maku
Pico is
but some one a few years ago built a
fake maccu picchu and they were taking
people to it just real idiots and they'd
put him on his boat this vessel and get
him over there she had all these people
in this fake-ass maccu picchu you know
meanwhile off the side you got a couple
bags a quick Creek because they just
built the [ __ ] and they're telling these
people that it's an ancient burial
grounds and it's an ancient pyramid and
it wasn't they busted those people but
thousands of people fell for it spent a
lot of money to go there and see a fake
maccu picchu so just different times but
you haven't talked to you guys I since I
came back from well this weekend I was
in I mean why were the last weekend this
is San Jose maybe it was San Jose was it
was a wonderful that was a blast this
weekend Oh last week it was Tempe was
Phoenix and it was cool man my mother
came out and it was the first time that
she didn't see me perform in five years
and it was cool man you know her husband
passed away recently about a about three
weeks ago
and you know it's interesting cuz I
never had a relationship with him mr.
Charlie that was hizmet that was his
name
and I never had a relationship with that
man really you know I was a kid when he
came around and I was real rebellious
anyway in my mind and in my heart and I
never you know he would take us over
there to the Holiday Inn get us a little
breakfast gets a little datas you know I
stuck a waffle french toast
different items and they put that
whipped cream on it and I mean that
whipped cream wish that should have been
whipped dude do you in Louisiana they
got some real whipped cream of a tear at
that Holiday Inn buffet over there
highway 190 they got the real deal
whipped cream I mean that cream has been
beaten bruh do must should had a boxing
glove in and I remember the whipped
cream that came on him hot cake like
damn what
yeah it [ __ ] was autographed by uh by
Buster Douglas you know that that cream
had been whipped dude
I was eating and next thing you know a
couple couple brothers came out and just
beat the [ __ ] out of the cream again on
the god damned huh I'm trying to eat
gentlemen they said sorry bud man we
just man we [ __ ] his cream up dude
that cream had been I mean this so I
remember that about that holiday in mr.
Charlie would take us over there and
take my mother out on Sunday and he
would take a tour brunch and if we'd
been well behaved and if he if he had a
little bit extra money he would get you
know he'd let us to tag along and we sit
there and and uh and then it and he
would get us that whipped cream on the
hotcakes and they put the I mean that
[ __ ] had been whipped one time some of
it you know kind of snuck over to me
some of the cream it was like hey Manny
you know they beaten us at the house man
I need some help I need some help
one time one some of the whipped cream
was like hey take this note man kit give
this to somebody who cares and I open
the note up it was like help us sign
cream like damn man they [ __ ] beaten
this cream around here she's it ain't
safe out in these cream streets boy
there's some scary dairy they got these
scary dairy actors around here uh but
mr. Charlie passed away man you know and
I know my mom was kind of you know it
kind of broke her heart a little bit and
and you know at first I didn't really
think about it I just you know because
he didn't really mean anything to me but
it took me an extra beat to kind of
think about well what did this man mean
to her you know and I've had I remember
a guy called a while a year a year and a
half ago he called and he was talking
about you know her he emailed me and he
said hey man you know I have to my mom's
getting married this weekend to a man
and I don't like him and
and I remember thinking well but does
your mom like him you know cuz it was
and and and and I'm glad I had that
moment with that guy that emailed
because it I needed I used that moment
the other day when I was like you know
it doesn't matter like I didn't have a
relationship with this man so Charlie
but he but he you know my mother cared
about him and so then you know I have
the choice to just care that she cares
and I don't know it was this interesting
man it was just kind of like a lot of
feelings and I try to be you know
supportive and and you know I have a
special story in my act now you know
that I do and uh and you know I got to
tell him um that I tell the story
because you know it gets to keep it
keeps mr. Charlie alive in her in her in
the world it keeps him alive you know
and that's one of the things about
stories is you know we man so many of
these stories nowadays they're not
there's no real there's no nobody's
giving you a story
nobody's giving us a story nobody's
given us his story used to be something
where you pass something down from
somewhere to somewhere else here's the
story here's a story the story did you
hear it you that's how a story was it
was something it was an L it was a piece
that needed to go on it something needed
to stay alive and now they got a lot of
Jackass storytellers out here they don't
know they don't have a story you know
and that's the press one of the things I
have you know I get I get a chip on my
shoulder with this industry out here
didn't have a [ __ ] story
none of these cats got a story out here
like oh what's your story
your daddy had everything you got
everything and that you never had it or
did think about anything or deal with
anything you went to some fancy fancy
school
where's you you don't even know anything
oh so you guys are gonna be you guys are
gonna produce a story you're gonna write
a story smoke da
okay Cameroon anyway I don't mean to get
angry at this you know I don't know but
it was nice to see my mother man and it
was nice to make her laugh you know when
you know one thing I that I did have I
had I had some moments where I was like
you know huh my mom was just you know
she's tired man she's been through a lot
and a lot of people's moms have you know
we give our and sometimes I do anyway
over the years I give I give my mom kind
of a tough time you know I mean there's
two places inside of me it's like hold
on bro I got him on that mucinex right
now and then I'm on about damn 60 grams
bro I'm saying I'll clear my throat and
[ __ ] remember I remember a question
from a math test in fourth grade dude
that's how this [ __ ] is strong it's
unlocking me that mucinex but you know
this and this time it was just all I
could do this time was just my mother I
didn't you know I didn't talk anything
about our things we thought about our
relationship ring I just tried to be
loving that was it you know I tried to
be loving I gave my mom some extra hugs
and you know and I've never really felt
that great hugging my mother we've never
been a good hug team like if there was a
team of huggers which how is hugging not
a sport dude this is what I would like
to do we should start a group that goes
around at night right you're all in
hoodies we roll up on some people like
2:30 a.m. in a scary city like New
Orleans or Chicago and we [ __ ] this
roll up and hug the [ __ ] out of somebody
they'd be like what the [ __ ] happened
feels so good just [ __ ] nine people
this hug man you got [ __ ] hugged boy
you better get don't make me [ __ ] hug
you again just hugging the [ __ ] out of
somebody and be crazy whenever maybe but
ever gonna be wild but yeah I just
trying to be loving to my mother man and
it was nice and my brother came as out
as well because he wanted to be
supportive him because mom had lost her
husband and yeah I don't know what I
feel about it I guess
I'm not trying to get all in the moon
thoughts and feelings here but you know
what it was nice man is I got to take my
mom to eat eat a couple times and I
didn't have to worry you know there's
something I think in your head somewhere
you always worry a little bit even if we
don't do it on purpose even if it's not
at the front of our head it's always a
worry in the back of our head you know
if our mother is okay I think a young
man thinks that so for me maybe maybe
not but for me it was a very nice time
of just you know just to see my mom
being okay and to know that she was okay
and and she had a nice time and and what
else has she showed up in the van and
that you know she got that 16 passenger
van with no side or rear windows and she
showed up and and we had fun man we had
a good time and so and yeah it was just
a time to just be loving and just you
know sometimes it's just you just go
onward right we just go onward it wasn't
about me and man that was fun over there
in Phoenix dude so many people came out
and I want to apologize some of those
shows I was shook I mean my nerves were
just rattled out my nerves were all
rattled out and uh I mean just like the
lungs on a damn [ __ ] Scarecrow in a
in a wind tunnel
I mean you I was rattled so those shows
I didn't feel like they were some of my
best but this weekend I you know it was
good we had I was over in Kansas City I
know I'm all over the place today guys
my brains little all over the place a
guy I got home this morning around 11:00
and then I took a nap and Here I am but
I'm grateful to be here I'm grateful to
be here I don't want you to think that
it's just a lot to catch up on and it's
different when a man has been in your
body like this you know Chris uh
Christopher Dawson he came in here into
my body
man hey this is our body and he was in
here climbing up and down our ribcage
you know
[ __ ] whistling at our he was doing
cat calls at our liver you know that's
it that's the kind of guy he is
and that's the kind of guy Christopher
Dahlia says he'll he'll he's the kind of
dude he'll put his head he'll put he'll
stick his head in you ass and [ __ ]
cat call your liver
you know he's that kind of that fellow
like that and he's always all wearing
fancy [ __ ] like Johnston and Murphy's at
airport you know that Airport
haberdashery and so that's who he is
but I was it was amazing to see that he
was here and then I was there and and it
was interesting dude in his place when
you walk around in his his home is it's
like a castle and you could hear dragons
somewhere he had a dragon I was like oh
I think somebody left their car running
and AH and they had like I don't want to
say a slave but they had some dude in
Chains and he's like oh no that that's
the dragon man they got a dragon down
there brother
I was like oh okay are you okay
and then he passed me a note he said uh
they whipping us cream said son my cream
I was like damn what is going on it's a
black mirror episode and that's not a
racial slur black mirror is not a racial
slur
so get your minds out of the racism
gutter what else is going on Oh somebody
made this if you look if your only
YouTube you can see this a man made this
out of wood I'm gonna hold it up close
to the it's me giving like a peace sign
it's not me I mean it's a it's a bust
it's a wooden bust of me and man it was
really nice of you to do that you know
it was really really nice of you thank
you very much that man's name is Shawn
Williams and he has a know-how Casey no
that's his email but Shawn Williams
illustrator writer fabricator out of
Kansas City you can look them up scae
and wi ll I am
and he sent me this little note it said
Theo your open vulnerability is really
inspiring thanks for being you and doing
what you do Gang Gang Shawn and it's
just a really nice piece and they had an
Italian restaurant
Carla Lazos in Kansas City they came out
and brought us some snacks Italian Oh
Garos they brought us some food over
there so that was nice of them thank you
very much and oh we went and got
barbecue so Kansas apparently a thing in
Kansas City people want you to have meat
in you and why the date you know whether
it's a tender gentleman kind of trying
to slip you up that freaking shank steak
or that [ __ ] you know he's trying to
give you that 19th rib in that back jaw
or rather it's you know them just
sending you to a spot to get a slab a
meat that's all anybody ask you there
have you had any barbecue hey what you
doing barbecuing all they want you to do
in Kansas City is get some [ __ ] meat
in your mouth I went to the dentist or
the doctor he's like open your mouth I
was like ah and he put a [ __ ] couple
of burnt ends and hit me with a damn
[ __ ] a couple of damn triangles a
tri-tip just freaking getting geometric
up on my mouth with him geomet geometric
you feel me he hit me with them
triangles of meat and that is Kansas
City they want you to have that by like
you dude if they had their all day if
they had a choice their alphabet would
be a b BQ d e f g that's all they care
about the BB q you know they even
introduced me to AA baby um then I met a
small Latino child there and his name
was bik you like what that's not a name
they love barbecue there I mean it is if
they if you fall asleep with your mouth
open somebody will put a [ __ ] a
little wall you know a little chicken
quarter in there they love barbecue you
know you could do anything
they do they have barbecue suppositories
at the gas station you could pick up you
know catch you about 2,000 milligrams of
[ __ ] pork sausage in a pill and just
pop that bastard in dude and still chew
that's how good the barbecue so pasta
tourists are you put one in that BJ
brewing that back jaw and then you still
chew and that's how tasteful the meat is
there and that's in the damn meat belt
but if I was a cow I'll be damned that's
why you don't see any cows or Veals out
there hitchhiking in Kansas City or in
Mazar some people say Mazar you know but
that's why you don't see any cows out
there
because they [ __ ] them up boy dude
they bro you'll see a dude with a
baseball bat he'll dip that [ __ ] into
some [ __ ] a1 and just beat the [ __ ]
out of an animal brah they ain't playing
over there
they love barbecue have you ever had
some barbecue have you been a 'slap-ass
have you been to Arthur Bryant's have
you been to stack's have you been uh
riblets everything if you had have you
been the arm you know spines like spines
that sounds uh who's uh who's the head
chef uh you know Bruce Bruce a barber
okay but yeah that Kansas City that they
want you to have the meat and they will
not stop until you get it you don't have
a dude he'll [ __ ] load a gun he'll
load a [ __ ] six-shooter with a couple
of [ __ ] cuts I am and just just pop
right off in your [ __ ] mouth until
you're full like oh that was great
it's a white dude is crazy dangerous
dude they had a drive-by shooting
somebody [ __ ] just just just filled
my frigerator up with baloney from
[ __ ] from the street with a bologna
gun boy with that Bologna again next you
know the meat and freezer is full of
venison and ball 9 but they want you to
have that Baba cue that meat that
Mexican baby you know but man it was
great man a lot of sisters people who
came out let me think they had a couple
of jack chicks some girl tried to sell
me a little bit of deck on some wind
straw
never seen net but we're not when the
animals doing drug cause animals do a
lot of [ __ ] steroids and we don't see
a lot of times at night animals are in
the [ __ ] gym you'll see a cow in
there just mmm doing weight you know
doing cattle bells okay that was too
much but these ladies man they uh who
else came out I mean people some twins I
saw some twins I saw a young met a young
man who was taking his daughter for a
walk
oh we did a single moms night and we
went go-karting with francesca and her
sister for single moms night and man
i'll say this this was uh I've gotten to
go out with some fun groups or Sur
mothers and their friend and this was a
mother and her sister and dude they were
a hilarious
she had French that's got five children
and she had four the fourth one one
ended up being twins so she got that
hitter she got that bonus cuz sometimes
one of your ovaries will start her a
little instead of getting one you'll get
two - you know what I'm a mean that was
quints so you got to you know you got to
be careful make sure yah - I get you I
get you ivory take your ovaries to a
speech pathologist and make sure that
they're just flowing naturally instead
of cysts a stutter Ranga but do we have
some fun went on the go-karts and then
they went out with their family and then
they came to the Late Show and and I'm
just I'm excited to follow up with her
this week but that was fun so I want to
thank everybody that supports our
patreon we're remodeling the patreon
right now and we're refocusing it mostly
on on charity and trying to find a
financial trying to find I'm looking
into how to start a non-profit so so
that everything can be done kind of
through they're putting a mission
statement together but thank you to
everyone who supports patreon because
that's what that's what we do that's
where we submit that's where we you know
fund and financed or subsidized taking
out single moms and then following up
with them and doing something special
for them also the single mother from
Kansas City we got a little Froyo those
ladies were wild and that one is up on
YouTube right now
someone I met someone called in I guess
and told me to tell a story let me see
if that's on this let me see
somebody said hey Theo will you tell the
story from when you were in at the loony
bin in Wichita so I'll tell you this so
I went to the loony bin in Wichita
Kansas and some people came out from
there this weekend and thank you and at
the loony bin they had I hadn't been
there and I didn't know that sometimes a
comedy club they'll put you in a little
house or of an apartment or comedy condo
or sometime they're [ __ ] one place
put you in a van out there Mishawaka
Indiana they had you stand a little van
and if you don't mind a van then you
don't mind it but if you mind a van then
you're not really gonna enjoy that style
of staying but so they put me in this
deal and and uh [ __ ] was I said I'm out
there
dude what's in my head brain icing on my
brain of ice or something I don't know
what it is like somebody trying to put
antifreeze in my brain and dope it down
like a [ __ ] act like a dog that's
being bad next door um okay so and after
the show I met this gal and she had that
real booty booty you know she had that
frickin that scar as the brothers and
you know is that cool people say these
days you know that's or like uh who's
that girl cardi B she's always like you
know good girl
and so this girl had that skirt skirt
booty you know I mean damn she was built
like a [ __ ] bison like dude I
wouldn't be surprised if you met her
mother and her mother was eating hay
somewhere you know because there's this
bad little B&E this beardy this bi they
had some beast in her you got me she
built like a damn bison bra you know she
did kind of girl who she just built that
back solder we just built like a day
I mean if she's shat in the yard you'd
be like aw whatever that's how they do
it she had that real animal-like
posterior so anyway she and I started
hooking up out in a van you know because
she had a van because she did um
cleaning she did house cleaning and for
me dude some of y'all know man I can I
get sexually nervous you know I get
sexually no no I can't [ __ ] around
certain stuff I can't be sexual you know
I can't be sexual around certain things
I can't get an erection around broken
glass I can't get an erection if the air
conditioners on I can't and if there's a
lot of cleaning products you know I'm
saying if you got more than one thing a
pine salt open within like about a 12
foot or eight foot probably eight to six
foot radius of me you won't catch me
doing sex boy not even not hard sex
anyway maybe a real calm you know kind
of library sex so you know she you know
this this girl gal had a van and we were
outside of the comedy club in this van
trying to get sexually engaged and that
she had a couple you know some things of
cleansers because she worked as a UH as
a Clint as a cleaning agent a cleaner
and so she she I guess something had
spilled or whatever so I'm trying to you
know be sexual and be fully upright you
know I'm trying to get ripen my loin and
uh and I can't do it because there's too
much cleaning fumes in the air you know
I just can't do what I just you know
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] smell the fumes
of those man it's hard for me I can't
even do library sex because if the the
Wafaa that cleanse are getting into my
damn doing you know dick simal system so
I'm [ __ ] I'm limping out so I said hey
well let's go into the place from stain
they'd put me up in a comedy they had a
house in a neighborhood the comedy club
owned a house back behind so I they had
a key and stuff in this where the
comedian state every week in this home
so I go in there would go down the hall
and me and this gal tried to engage
somewhat you know and I did we engage in
sex who knows man nobody has left more
women in America unsatisfied
oh yeah but morning you know so I'm that
[ __ ] I'm that hitchhiker that you
pick up and he don't even talk no I'm
saying that's the scariest one sometimes
you get that hitchhiker and he all he
does is rattle off and he's just
hammering away with those words and
sometimes you get that hitchhiker and he
just barely say nothing you know he
barely contributes he's that shitty
Whisperer and that's kind of high and
when it comes to sexual you know I
definitely come in probably bouts forty
maybe forty or 60th place out of not
that many people out of probably 30
people
so anyway next thing I know I hear an
alarm going off an alarm
and it sound like what I got open the
room door and this is a house this is
the room I'm standing is in a house and
I thought the whole house myself there's
a woman standing there in a nightgown
she has an alarm clock that she plugged
into the wall and he's like set the
alarm clock so it would go off right
then and now it's going off she's
standing there and she's like you can't
have any guests here and I mean this is
2:30 in the morning and I'm like who are
you are you like another comedian she
goes no I'm the manager I'm the manager
of the club or the assistant manager or
whatever you know Delores or I think the
law is something she goes I live here I
stay here and one of the rules is you
can't have any guests in the house and
like one of the rules should also be
that you can't be [ __ ] Stephen King's
sidepiece boo boo because you woke me up
and I say woke up even though I was
having sex but even though when I'm
having sex it's really very similar to
you know being at rest to being asleep
boy I got that dormir saying my dick you
feel me that duermo and and so I was
like what what you know you could have
just knocked on the door you could have
said something you could have used you
know your dubby is your words but this
lady stood there with an alum clock I
mean stringy hair wearing just a
nightgown
I mean like Stephen King's little I mean
just like some like just somebody that
you know just sold dirty dishware you
know at Stephen King's old soda shop she
just it was just I don't know very
alarming so anyway then I had to go back
on into this van so now me and his girl
out in his van dude and whatever anyway
I don't know why I told you guys all
that but that was the story in Wichita
at the loony bin and when I got what I
mean I got woken up out of an out of a
sexual interaction and by a woman
standing in and I'm this study is
probably 45 50 standing in a hall and
I've never been in this house before
imagine you're in there you're engaged
you know you sensually engaged you know
seeing if the lower one saw how well the
Lord cares about the two of you and then
you open the do you hear an alarm clock
outside of the bedroom door and you open
it and there is a woman standing there
in a nightgown saying you can't have any
guests Jesus so that's what happens
that's what happens but a stories
anticlimactic
but not an anticlimactic is a lot of the
sex I've been involved in I'll tell you
this though my boy
and it's interesting to call this guy a
buddy but we've kind of become buddies
over the past year and I'm proud of him
I'm happy to know him and I'm so excited
he's fighting out of Louisiana and out
of Florida Dustin Poirier fights for the
interim lightweight 155-pound title this
Saturday in Atlanta at the UFC 236 and
I'm damn I'm nervous man I'm nervous for
him I'm nervous for everybody do it I
would be nervous to even go up there and
lock the little gate the gate lock the
gate the gate on the cage you know but
man it's gonna be interesting what else
happened let's go to some calls here we
go hey Renee thank you for
colin appreciate you reaching out
homeward I just left your Saturday Late
Show in Kansas City and I met you after
and I was so [ __ ] nervous but
remember taking a picture in your check
out everybody coming up to you I just
want to say you killed the show it was
on Sunday and my friends had a blast and
you know that lady offense rep just a
[ __ ] show I know you probably felt
like you know everything was thrown off
but you got back into it it was awesome
it didn't change a thing for us at least
from everything and I appreciate
everything that you do well thank you
that's very sweetie to say and thank you
for driving over from MA from mum was it
Lansing let me hear again calling funny
lives in Kansas Lanting Renee thank you
that's nice you to say yeah you know I
have a problem that well yeah that lady
was drunk
that lady was you're wrong I mean she
was just sure she was shook like a dang
you know just like a sick hooker and a
tornado but she was shook down and and
yeah you know I just I have this thing I
want the show to be fun all I just want
everybody able to be able to hear what's
going on and then I've been a little bit
stressed out and so I don't handle some
of those situations well sometimes and
it was calm you know like I you know the
lady yelled out I couldn't run she
yelled and I tried to like embrace it
and then she did it a couple more times
and then they ended up just to ask her
to leave or I might have asked her to
leave I don't even remember I mean in
those moments I just want to get back to
her so many people are having fun and
I'm having fun that I just want us to
keep doing that but I think once I'm
able to take relax a little bit and take
a break a little I think I'll be able to
get into more of a comfortable space
where I can handle those moments better
you know I have this weird I don't have
this weird I have this thing where it's
like I need everything I want everything
to go how I want it to go
um and that's a character defect it's
something that's wrong you know it's
it's like I want everything to be
perfect I want everything to be perfect
you know and what I need to realize is
Moe everything's gonna happen however
it's gonna happen so I need to work on
something a little bit more but you
being saying that very sweet of you to
let me know that everything still came
off smoothly because yeah and my mind
then everything gets rattled and things
aren't going super but that wasn't the
case oh let's take another call here the
hotline as always as nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three you know
and a lot of young men and you know a
woman came out and told me that her
husband just got 30 days of sobriety and
that was on the stage and uh after one
of the shows and man that really hit me
in the heart you know and they you know
people will say hey man I'm grateful to
you and thank you and and that's sweetie
to say you know I just I don't you know
these are you you guys are doing any you
do you are doing things to make yourself
better you know and and I and I
appreciate the kind words but but I said
I want to say congrats congrats to you
congrats to you for whatever little
challenge it is in your life you trying
to take back your willpower take back
your you know you're trying not to do
this or trying to do this it could be
anything from sugar to sobriety to you
know to not tune with your mouth but I
don't care what it is but anytime you're
trying to challenge yourself for
self-betterment good for you because
they got this world around us that don't
they doesn't want us to think about it
it doesn't want it wants us to just limp
into the drain that it's created and
just become this gelatin that just
slowly goes down the drain but we want
to make ourselves be of something
because their cells do their cells
inside of us that know each other that
want to do something and that
want to do good when they are best
serviced in that interesting well what
worked what makes us work is a series of
sales a team work we have a team we are
built up of a team inside of us and it's
fascinating to me it's fascinating to me
that we we are built we are a team and
our smallest level we are a team of
molecules that has to work together for
life to occur I don't know why I went
off on that but I mean I'm talking about
but you can hit the hot line as always
with uh well I just want to say yeah if
you you know thank you guys you know for
anybody that says something to me it
says like thank you and I'm glad to be
I'm glad to be I'm glad you that we are
part of each other's lives you know I
said this on stage this weekend and I
don't feel I feel like what we have here
is a cool group man we got a cool group
I swear it's crazy bro but I really feel
like I think we can find some positive
ways to do things in the world and we're
gonna do it and I don't feel like I'm
the chick the spearhead of that group I
didn't feel like I'm one of the group
members and uh and I'm just excited and
it's but it but it's nice to see so many
people come out man it's funny some
people are nervous some young guy you
know some guys are joking around I feel
bad that I'm not sometimes uh this at
the end of the show's went under
nostalgia and so it's hard for me to
someone else to fully engage in a in his
meaningful away but I decided I think
before Australia I might take a little
vacation and and do that and just get
some rest and not do anything you know
not do anything but um but just try and
find some just think just trying to
think about gratitude and just be
grateful yeah because I get to do I
honestly I get to do what I love right
now and I want to thank you guys for
that let's take another call nine eight
five six six four nine five zero three
here we go all right before we get to
that call actually I want to let you
know that today's episode is also
brought to you by Bedell again
and I'll show you right here I got a
half you know probably a half court I
got 18.6 fluid ounces of this bad booty
juice right here and Bedell against is a
natural cleansing foam that brings you
the luxury and elegance of a bidet with
the convenience of toilet paper think
about this if you had to have a real bad
day and carry it around with you
everywhere but days are made out of
cement or beautiful white cement
sometimes and but elegance is basically
bidet in a can much lighter to carry you
apply but elegance moisturizing
cleansing foam the toilet paper and to
wet clean and dry your private areas
both front and back get those front and
back outer outer areas because sometimes
you got to run a you know sometimes you
do your and sometimes you do a you know
kind of a you know a strong urine out of
the back
but elegance it's better than both dry
toilet paper and wet wipes it's cost
effective anti-inflammatory so your
butts gonna be calm when you're done
it's soothing keeps your hands dry does
not harm sewer systems and it's
eco-friendly Marisa gave it five out of
five stars
she's an Amazon review from an Amazon
review from an actual tpw listener she
said I purchased this product due to
Theo von recommending this to me on his
podcast he said that if I couldn't
afford a bidet this would be the next
best solution and I can't afford a bidet
well I currently rent my residence and I
don't think my landlord of the HOA would
be happy with me installing one bow wise
lady here plus my bathroom is tiny and I
would not have anywhere to put it unless
I pulled the shower out maybe okay
getting a little OCD here but anyway I
am cleaner than ever thanks bud elegance
and Theo well you're welcome Marisa she
gave it five out of five stars
but elegance is available right now on
amazon.com for 10% off and free shipping
use promo code 1 0 th EO vo in that's
the number 10 Theo von no spaces that's
ten percent off and free shipping using
ten Theo von as your code when you go to
Amazon
come but delegates get that bottom
hitter was out of thinking I was
thinking my son wanted to share you know
was think about the other day was our
fingerprint
nettie you know sometimes we don't feel
like individuals maybe or we don't feel
like our life has like we're not
sometimes let me let me speak for myself
sometimes I'll have times where I don't
feel like I'm of value in the world and
I'm not getting into into a depression
hole here but I'm just saying we all
have we said we all have those moments
we feel like well maybe we don't mean
that much or well is there something is
there something I'm part of I ask myself
like you know you start to get a little
older like what what are what is life
mean does it mean anything I'm that I'm
a an individual person or does it just
mean that I'm just part of something a
group that I'm a person one of many do
people mean anything do we as a group of
humans do we mean something do we do we
have a purpose here like are we able to
see our bigger purpose is there any
value to me being an individual and I
started thinking about fingerprints you
know that even twins don't have the same
fingerprint that's fascinating I think
and in your eyes the only other thing I
think in the human body that is unique
to each person each person in the
history of time that means no there
wasn't a person 4000 years ago that has
the same retina I was at the doctor the
other day and the doctor said that the
eye man and he said that he said you
know no one has the same retinas I'm
like damn well you a [ __ ] pervert boy
you know you got here peeping tom and on
people on people's peepers where are you
looking right in the eyes I'm [ __ ]
looking for that individuality but in
that fascinating that that our
fingertips
our fingerprints are unique the the
exact things we touch the world with
that we interact with others with no one
else has the same exact ones now to me
that's you know I'm not a big
religiosity big religiosity you know I
believe that I want there to be
something bigger than me and I believe
that there is something bigger than me
out there
I know that there is for me you don't
have to if you don't want to that's you
I as you eat we all get to do it our own
way
but the simple fact that there is
purpose and me being me there's purpose
that in the way that I touch the world
and even in my retinas and in my
fingertips the two things you kind of
used to really interact to really where
you could really touch someone sometimes
you can touch someone with your eyes you
know and you and they can touch you
someone sometimes people can give you a
look and you feel touched or sometimes
you can touch someone and your hands
obvious you could touch someone that's
primary touches touching areas but to
think that you have your own print
everyone no one's ever gonna have yours
to me that's fact that is to me that's
in my own little world way that I
interact with the world that is that is
some that's some hardcore and you know
proof that there's value to us as
individuals and sometimes when I feel
like there isn't for me that brings me
because I can look at my fingers too
that's what's interesting I can I can
just look directly at my fingerprints
and like wow you know I am important I
don't know I'm kind of rambling here I
think I don't even know I'm talking
about but I think this is just what you
get this sometimes these episodes are
all different you know and I'm just um
man I can't believe that guy made this
nice statue thing out of wood what a
neat thing what a neat thing that a
police officer brought me a badge this
weekend from his work someone
in ice came to the city hat some fella
gave me his hat another woman gave me a
nice KC baseball cap very sweet of her
people brought food some man brought
some barbeque and that's you know why
Missouri is a wonderful place man it's
very it's got it's got it's got a lot
going on it's got a lot of history it's
got a lot of grit you know we went to
see that the childhood home of Jesse
James and where he was buried and so a
lot of people was an outlaw some people
said he was a Robin Hood he was like a
Confederate sort of uh he was like I can
like you know I think Missouri was
neutral in the Civil War and he kind of
like he didn't support one side directly
or the James Gang didn't but they kind
of low-key would like [ __ ] with the
Confederate the Union soldiers and they
would started robbing banks and trains
that were in business with the or that
were started by the Union soldiers or
started by Union people from the north
union bigwigs fancy and some people said
that they were the Robin Hood's that
they did things that gave money away and
and I don't know if that's true or not
something that that is kind of disputed
you know some documentaries dispute
things but you know a documentary is
just the way somebody wants you to see
something so much sometimes it can be
the way somebody wants you to see
something so much that they make a
perfect way for you to see it that way
like I don't always just believe
documentaries I mean if it's something
real factual like you know there was a
murder and this is what happened and
this guy went to jail and this is that
but if it's something like you know
where it's like we don't really know you
know it's just a perception cuz there
you know there's documentary type of
stuff where it's like Oh Jesse James was
a Robin Hood and then there's
documentary type of stuff for Jesse
James was just uh up to no good just
selfish boy but um but but each someone
can make a documentary to really infuse
infuse you either way it just reminds me
to keep my eyes
I don't know what I'm [ __ ] and I'm
sorry I'm getting kind of preached here
today let's go on to another question
here we go nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three is the is the
hotline number and you can call there
and leave a voicemail and be a part of
this saw club podcast sorry I got to
take my eye on my nasal spray real quick
and that's not cocaine that's licensed
nasal spray from a doctor let's go
oh hey Theo hey this is dawn from
Seattle and I just I couldn't Ben list a
lot of your podcast recently and my son
he said hey Dad what are you learning
from those from his podcast and I said I
thought about it and you know I think
what I'm learning is I appreciate your
just your chill attitude and you seem to
take take life as it comes and and you
know you take people as they come and
that's sometimes the problem with them
I'm kind of an uptight guy and just
video I thought my daughter she's 16
with her with her algebra homework and
sometimes I get a little tense
I get frustrated and she gets frustrated
but I don't know I was just I was just
kind of it was right after to listen
your podcast and just felt very relaxed
and I felt very accepting and just
patient that's amazing patience oh yeah
I think I told myself I think I'm
learning patience I think I've learned
how to be relaxed and I'm not sure if
it's your southern nature or you're just
you're you're very accepting chill
attitude but anyways I just want to say
thank you do the good work I think
through blessing people and you know the
universe also and anyway onward gang
gang gang gang brother oh that's sweet
man to think of a dad working with his
what is what his daughter and doing her
and doing the homework thanks for the
nice words man that's sweet of you you
know I uh I mean I struggle I think I
struggle with everything just like we
all do and and but I'm glad that there's
moments where you find some some comfort
from from this podcast and a lot of
times it could be from people calling in
you know it was interesting when you
were talking it made me think of like
like a moment there sometimes I noticed
in my life Riesling there's moments for
uh for vulnerability and you know you're
talking about like when you're with your
daughter
and you're helping her with the homework
and you get frustrated and she gets
frustrated so then in that moment and
this man and this may not apply to your
life but if I'm in a moment where I'm
frustrated at someone and they're right
there and I know they're frustrated with
me and I know that I'm frustrating I
know that I am I was built they got up
you know they put that the frustration
of sauce on me when I was born and so
I'm out here dripping with frustration a
little bit constantly you know um and so
uh in that moment we're both you were
frustrated sometimes if you can find a
way to say hey are you frustrated with
me and they say yeah I am and you can
say yeah I'm frustrated you know I feel
a little frustrated with you - maybe we
can really talk for a second about why
what do we think is making us frustrated
with each other you know what sometimes
I find that I get frustrated with people
and if I'm
honest if I'm then you have to be trying
to be real honest and it's hard
sometimes you have to really feel you
can't just talk you have to just feel
like man I'm frustrated because
sometimes you don't in the truth for me
in a moment like that is I get
frustrated with the other person because
they don't do things the way that I want
them to do them and and then I can ask
why do what frustrates you and it's like
and for them it might be well you don't
have the patience sometimes that I need
it makes me I feel under pressure when
I'm doing something with you because I
don't feel like it's a safe area to
learn a safe moment to learn in because
you know you're expecting me to know
something at a certain speed that I'm
not able to and then once you guys can
both kind of really share what you're
you know what your real kind of fear is
or what your anger is then you can kind
of then you can kind of say if for me I
can say hey look well you know I'm real
sorry that I am you know that I behave
in a way sometimes where you know I make
you feel like you like I expect you to
know things at my pace and not occurs
and I want to do a better job because I
love you and because I care about you
and and then they can say you know well
I really want to be here with you and
learn and try and work together to learn
something and I'm gonna try to to just
let you know and I feel like you're not
being patient in a more comfortable way
and man you can have some real powerful
moments and I'm not preaching at you I'm
not telling you to do that or anything
but I'm saying that I sometimes I found
myself doing that you know when my
ex-girlfriend when we get in a moment
I'd be frustrated sometimes would be
really hard to just be like you know
just what I would love it if you'd be
real honest why you're frustrated with
me and and then I can be real honest
about why I'm frustrated with myself in
the situation um I don't know I don't
know what all that's about man but but
it's interesting sometimes in moments of
frustration that there's a real
opportunity for some vulnerability and
some just the ability to to feel cuz I
get otherwise I will run brother I'll
run with this senseless just like these
vultures that are like trying to get out
of my throat or neck or skin that are
just agitated and if I you know so I
gotta find a way to sue these vultures
in the real
way to sue them is to just tell Pitts
tell someone that I care about that I
have these vultures and on that I wish I
didn't and I want to try harder not to
have them and anyway I don't know I'm
talking about man I [ __ ] need some
sleep probably but thank you for calling
man and that's it sweetie you to be a
dad that helps out you're her daughter
your daughter with her homework and uh
and I bet that that's a moment that
you're always gonna love you know it's
gonna be a sweet moment you know because
they've come times and kids lives I'm
sure where they don't want they don't
care what your direction or angle is you
know and you don't have to help her you
get to help her that's one thing I
remind myself someday you know like I
don't have to come do this podcast I get
to come do it it's a gift you know it's
a gift to be able to come and sell this
frickin booty lotion to people that
nespa delicates
but thank you for calling man let's take
another call homeward hey Theo
it's a Carter from Oregon what's up
Carter from Oregon homeward by the way
my sister's a mother you see like your
arms but your sister likes my arms thank
you I got a pretty medium length
actually he said that got long arms and
then I buddy of mine showed me his arms
about guess two years ago three years
ago and [ __ ] kind of [ __ ] me up more
the real question is I'm looking for em
names for puffy okay I'm leaning on
Maggie and may need some names hook it
up with some suggestion em names for
puppies here's one Mississippi and you
could call the puppy Missy marxism and
that is a I don't know what marxism is
but mark set go
that could be the puppy's name and then
every time you call the puppy some
people would start racing each other
Martin name if it's a kind of a funny
dog that's kind of like a you know maybe
African American and it and it's really
really humorous and put him and is able
to make television shows you could call
it Martin you could call it on Moriarty
call it Maury if it's a Jewish dog you
could call it a
a mixtape mixtape is kind of a kind of a
cute name um let me think mincemeat
that's a crazy name for a dog oh that's
a little mincemeat right there and he
got some cigarettes em names for dogs I
think Maggie is cute it's a popular name
but it's a safe name
I think Millie is good
Mable maple Marble mobile Moxie you know
you want something where when you yell
it it doesn't sound like any kind of
racial slurs either so you got to be
careful with that let's take one more
call here here we go and also other I
got to tell you this though you know
that oh I'll be coming up soon I'm going
to be in West Palm Beach at the end of
this month the 27th and 28th I believe
we may add some more shows there they're
staying busy right now with those shows
but we we may add more I want to let you
know that today's episode is also
brought to you by we got a pack of me
undies right here got an unneeded some
dude oh I masturbated this weekend I
forgot to tell you and I felt shy oh and
I broke my pornography thing and I don't
even think I could on my phone and I
started thinking about dying just I was
feeling lonely started thinking about a
little bit of be whole you know and
stuff like that you know that female
bebe and uh and then I just did it there
I just kept rubbing on my body until you
know until until just something just
came out of it and I guess I feel kind
of disappointed in myself you know I and
then I did that was on I think Thursday
night and I didn't do it on Friday and
then last night I couldn't go to sleep
and I had to and so then I then I
masturbated but
but the big thing is I looked at the
pornography and we'll talk about it more
next week I'd love to know I know that
some guys that came out this week that
had been looking at pornography and
they'd taken a break from it I'd love to
know honestly be very honest on the
hotline how that's affected you and
what's going on now with you once you've
had a sabbatical from pornography and
I'm gonna get into that next week about
some of the changes I've been noticing
to myself since I had been ceased
watching pornography and I had probably
about 107 days or something so man and
Swit you know I don't want to talk about
it right I'll talk about it next week
cuz we've already gone and I don't know
what we've talked about this this
episode what else ongoing Arrowsmith I'm
going to Aerosmith in Las Vegas this
week so I'm so excited about that on
Thursday Thursday night and I'm taking
producer Nick so it's a gift and a you
know a team-building exercise exercise
from us and we're gonna go there and
watch some Aerosmith dream um and uh and
i'ma stay in Las Vegas and then I'm
going to the Dustin Poirier fight in
Atlanta and I can't wait to see that the
diamond now today's episode is also
brought to you by me undies look if you
want to support the podcast there's a
couple ways you can do it you can
support through patreon but you can also
support by getting me on these it's easy
go get a pair if you never had a pair of
get him I love them no joke I wear them
everyday
they're in my underwear a little drawer
and they look colorful when I get in
there and they're fun a little bit it's
one moment in my day where I get to put
a little bit of fun on my body and
there's a man you know it feels nice to
just wrap something around you junk
that's [ __ ] that feels good you know
this is not your wife or another man you
probably spend about 90% of your life
and underwear on if you know that so
don't think don't you think you owe it
to yourself to make sure you're wearing
the softest undies in town
that's why I'll only wear me undies me
undies are the softest underwear mug
here here that
oh my god boy what does that leprosy
this stuff is soft me undies use the
coveted micro modown fabric three times
softer than cotton they give you
multiple style options for both men and
women and these are cool they have
mixtapes on these actually have cassette
tapes that's pretty cool for that 80s
vibe and these are those basic blues
right there they have different styles
different body type they give you
multiple styles for both men and women
you can try the new box or breathe with
that fly which is the same great cut as
box or brief but now with an added
option for guys who prefer to go through
the gate verse over the fence if you're
still going through the gate bow that is
why old I got a throw that friggin hoes
over the fence then me undies has a
great offer from my listeners for any
first-time purchasers when you get any
me undies you get 15% off and free
shipping so every time you get an
individual pair so good get some
individual pairs and you'll get 15% off
each pair and you get free shipping get
15% off the most comfortable undies you
will ever put on to get your 15% off
your first pair free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee go to meet undies
dot-com / weekend w ee k ind that's me
undies dot-com / weekend and thank you
guys and see you look well I will never
try to sell some of this podcast that I
don't believe in people have sent ads
for things says hey what you sell I
don't know ice on that I don't take
every ad that comes to Nam my sound
that's people I think that's junk you
know that mystery game show thing I
finally played that where you pay for it
by mail I think my piece of [ __ ] the
cast for masters is I thought then was
piece of [ __ ] bro and now it took I had
to get one and try it and that's why I
felt and also these just my perceptions
other people's can be different but if I
know that something is not worth what
they're charging I'm not gonna sell it
you know you find somebody else to sell
that boy I'm not gonna sell that dude
but but I want to thank everybody in
Missouri that supported this weekend I'm
gonna get through this right here and uh
and what else man I know today's episode
was all over the place but I do want to
talk more about you know one thing it
was nice was when my when my brother and
mother came out there to Phoenix and and
and it was a night we hadn't all been
together since just the three of us
since we're probably maybe since I was
probably two years old or three years
old and and especially with that model
my mom didn't have to work we have to do
anything
let it be nice and so did I so did so
did my mother and so did my brother none
of us chose to dwell on anything or to
bring it up and sometimes you sometimes
you sometimes it's good to bring stuff
up but this time it wasn't and and it
was nice man it was nice it was nice to
sit there and listen to my brother talk
to me and share information that he
knows and things about the world because
he's a little bit older than me and a
little bit more experienced and it was
nice to see my mother just you know give
my brother a hug you know and like and
just have a moment with her son that she
probably hadn't had in a long time you
know it's nice to see my mother
you know get a you know at the dinner
table she put both of she put her hand
on my brother's hand on my hand at the
same time and it was a nice man it's
nice I fingerprints you know it's nice
too it's nice just
know that even though we had you know
had both had all lived so much lives you
know we'd all live for 30 you know
between 30 40 70 years that's still
inside of us there's the the people can
connect that human connection is it's
ageless it's ageless now isn't it
fascinating to know that there is a
there's like a yarn or a thread between
human beings that doesn't whether it
doesn't I mean it endures it weathers
but it doesn't it's always so quickly it
can be taught so quickly it can be
tightened so quickly it can be accessed
you know there's something amazing about
that it's amazing how forgetful human
touch is you know human touch doesn't
remember all of them a lot of the pain
and the anger or the the memories of the
uncomfort it just you know just let
somebody know hey I'm here you know I'm
here you know I'm here you're here it's
amazing like yeah you can just touch
somebody in almost ah you can almost
with a touch you never let somebody know
hey every you know I don't know it's
just interesting it's interesting the
powers that go on in human touch I guess
I got to learn more about it dr.
Perlmutter came in here last week and so
I have I agreed to to do that man's diet
so I am going to do that I want to begin
I want to try well I succeed I don't
know he kind of put me on it at the end
real and he was kind of you know you
talked to these book guys and they're
kind of smarty to me sometime they get a
little they know a little too much for
me but maybe I'm just jealous because
they know a lot or I'm envious you know
but he came in here dr. Perlmutter and
he's you know he knows about stomachs
and brains and he's singing to help you
know I want my brain in my life to be
the best I can and it's gonna take more
work for the way that I eat and the
things I choose to eat and I've been
doing all week I did good I did the keto
all week since I left since I left to go
out of town or all last week for a whole
week and then I [ __ ] lost my mind at
one moment and had three haagen-dazs ice
cream bars and at the third one couldn't
even taste it
that's the you ever get to that point
really like oh I'm just still eating it
but I can't even taste it like y'all met
on that 16th cookie or like I've no
[ __ ] clue what these taste like
anymore my body is my sugar and it's
maxed out but I'm still [ __ ] doing it
whatever you know what I think maybe um
maybe we've done enough you know I'm
thankful that Chris D'Elia came in here
thankful that we're back here in the
studio it's interesting it was so crazy
being in his place because it's a
different energy it's just different and
you know I'm grateful to our producer
Nick and his producer Juan hire and uh
and just you know we did something fun
we did something fun and and and so many
cool messages came in from from people
supporting the podcast
yep again support the podcast me undies
dot-com slash weekend is that code
kaptara comm slash Theo for your
business software solutions I'll be
coming up I'll be at the Palm Beach West
Palm Beach improv April 26th and 27th
very excited about that it looks like
we're gonna be able to interview riff
raff who is a kind of an estranged human
performer one of a kind be able to
interview him who else is coming up on
the podcast soon Jim Gaffigan is gonna
be coming in studio big baby Glen Davis
is supposed to be coming in studio we
have a lot of neat people and I'm so
excited to go to my first you have seat
by this week and see Aerosmith it's
gonna be crazy
sorry to brag but I never go do anything
like that I think everybody in Kansas
City that came out thank you for your
love and your support and it's never too
late it's never too late we got to
remember that you know it's never late
too late to have a new experience I
guess you know but you have fingerprints
been a fascinating aren't they they're
fascinating no one else has these no one
else has them so if you don't think
you're unique just I mean literally if
ten pieces of proof right there in front
of you are and your toes who even
[ __ ] knows if we have toe prints I
mean Jesus Christ who knows be good to
yourselves you know and uh because we
deserve it man we deserve it thank you
guys I'll see you next week
Stevie starlight come over
incise let's um